yeah chapter two of the war for
cybertron trilogy known as earthrise
it's out don't really know why it's
called earth right
did you know that no for i know it's
like
i'm kind of curious as to the views this
video will get
because when the first war for cybertron
siege
came out i heard about it like you know
it was in the comments section i don't
even have social media and i heard about
it a lot
this one no one's really talking about
it i found out about it because i was on
netflix for cobra kai and i was like oh
dwarf cyber
okay we gotta watch that so we'll see
how this video does
and we'll see if people are just
interested or they care
but hey let's start it
[Music]
transformers war for cybertron earthrise
so earthrise is chapter 2 the second
season
the sophomore chapter of this war for
cybertron trilogy on netflix and i'm
going to go ahead and give you a spoiler
warning as always not a play-by-play
but just i'm going to go into some
spoilerish things that
the trailer even showed saw the trailer
after i saw this
show i was like well you showed that wow
that point is better safe than sorry so
there's your warning all right so for
last season
optimus prime took the all spark
otherwise known as that
20-sided dice from magic the gathering
and he threw it up through the portal
took it off of cybertron might have
doomed them all
in this season even optimus prime's like
probably wasn't smart so optimus prime
is some other autobots get on a ship
they go through that portal some
autobots are still on cybertron
with the decepticons and megatron it's
all right we have our parties split up
and now
we're on the hunt a hunt that isn't
always smooth and sometimes it feels a
little jumpy i'll say right out the gate
this
it's six half hour long episodes
probably could have been 10
maybe 12. i feel like there's supposed
to be more in here it just seems kind of
jumpy in some parts like there's
one scene where megatron's like sweet i
got my ship and then you know he's
he's found optimus prime now he's just
kind of there he knows where he is i
feel like there could have been
something in between there but sure
but really my favorite part of this
whole thing is megatron
megatron is just shrewd he's evil he is
megatron squared nay cubed you can tell
i mean he has his reasons for doing what
he
does but the ends don't justify the
means he's taking transformers
decepticons i was like oh you were boone
didn't battle
instead of you know giving him a medal
he's like i'll just go ahead and recycle
you for energon because i need energy
he's a really twisted bad guy and that
voice is just
menacing and deep the guy is just
business and whenever he comes on screen
i'm entertained as hell also there were
some moments with the autobots like
optimus prime bumblebee
that whole crews out there in their
space adventure like that creepy
spinning head thing or
okay i'm gonna let you know they're
gonna be some characters
some things some terminology i'm not
gonna know because i enjoyed
transformers
but the lore has grown exponentially
long after i
stopped watching transformers so yeah
i'm gonna call that spinny head thing
and there are some things you're going
to recognize
and hear from transformers of the movie
not the transformers movie but
transformers of the movie yeah and
transformers movie you know the spinning
heads like
something like dropping transformers
yeah spinny head robots always creeped
me out so now we have
tentacley spinny head robot in here and
still creeps me out but the autobots
that are still on cybertron at first it
seemed very important and then that arc
just kind of
it doesn't end it just leaves off it
leaves off to the point where the
tension's climbing and then
megatron has found optimus prime in his
crew
and you're like did i miss something i
actually had to go back and rewind it i
was like no it just kind of
leaves off and i get there's a whole
other season chapter
six half hour long episodes to come
after this but i'm kind of with
optimus prime megatron the autobots and
decepticons
on that adventure i've kind of left
cybertron behind
so we'll see if i care so there is this
uneven wave of what's important what's
not important oh hey that looks
important but all right that just kind
of left off and it felt a little choppy
for the first couple episodes there's
even this whole thing where
they take way too much time fighting
scorpenoc who's this
huge transformer in here i've personally
never seen scorpion awk be this
important
never knew he was this much of a big
deal and maybe they wanted to spend more
time on it because it's like oh no
autobots and decepticons are fighting
but i don't know i just
kind of came right off cobra kai that's
the basis of that whole show is
enemies fighting to take on the bigger
enemy so yeah when autobots and
decepticons fight scorpenoc they have to
team up it's just
it didn't feel new or anything but in
those last couple episodes my favorite
thing my favorite part my favorite cameo
definitely galvatron because galvatron's
always been awesome and
again that throws back to transformers
the movie yeah he comes in with his
whole time travel shenanigans which
again
we're seeing a lot of that in everything
there's always time travel shenanigans
even when maybe it's not time travel
shenanigans it's made to look like it
like i still don't know what those
retcon ghosts are in the final fantasy 7
remake i have no idea
but it seemed a bit more time travelly
than i would have expected from final
fantasy vii
upon execution we'll see but yeah
galvatron because if
you don't know galvatron was megatron
who was turned into galvatron
although i hear that there are a couple
different ways galvatron's been
illustrated there's one where it's like
yeah galvatron got an upgrade
but he's still megatron but you know
he's super megatron now and in other
lore it's like no galvatron's
a different being than megatron it was
just kind of
made from him that's what i hear anyway
and i always kind of saw megatron and
galvatron like gandalf the grey and
gandalf the white galvatron comes to
megatron is like
let's go ahead and change history
because my life kind of sucks
because he is you know he's on the leash
of unicron it's the [ __ ] place to be but
at the end when unicron kind of gets
word of it and he's like
so when unicron's calling galvatron back
galvatron's like hey use this and yeah
you're not seeing [ __ ] that's the record
from voyager 1 and that
is in beast wars so i thought that was
kind of neat a big
gripe i have about this whole thing is
optimus prime
i gave optimus prime a pass last season
so i was like oh he's like this youthful
prime
and you know i get it he's trying to
figure it out he's a young leader and i
saw some people talking it's like dude
optimus prime's an idiot in this show i
don't like that so now after
earthrise i'm like yeah optimus prime's
kind of an idiot and i don't like that
either he's just a [ __ ] leader what can
i say
i i question his ability to effectively
lead the autobots
i move for a vote of no confidence in
optimus prime's leadership because it's
like i mean dude you're at war
and you're the leader of a band of
rebels
going against this really ruthless
leader and his
really vicious army of decepticons you
have to be able to make the tough calls
you have to be able
to pull the trigger on the battlefield
and it's like they pull the trigger to a
point but
anytime optimus prime has megatron
he doesn't kill him he doesn't take him
down he doesn't take him out and of
course megatron flips that scenario and
tries to kill optimus prime then optimus
prime gets him again he's like
not gonna do it maybe i should have last
time but i feel like it's gonna be
different this time and then you know
megatron just acts like megatron and
tries to kill him again it's like dude
prime at what point are you just
not a good war leader because that's
where we're at you know like the
autobots are at
war you need a war leader also a lot of
autobots kill a lot of decepticons in
the show which is kind of
that's war but it's like optimus prime's
like no i just kind of
that ain't me man they were all fine
working together
to kill skorpinock they were all
shooting him in the face
like yeah what were they trying to not
kill him when shooting him no
i'm not saying this to have the moral
conversation of the moral dilemma of
like oh when is it okay to kill or not
i'm just talking about effective
leadership and i think that hit me when
i was watching the show and we ran into
the scenario where it's like
even batman from the nolan batman's who
doesn't kill people
even megatron would have died if batman
was there it was like there's a scene
where megatron's impaled and megatron
even brings up like
all you have to do is do nothing and you
win i die so in a world wherein batman
begins you know batman had rae chalgool
and rachel goes like if he finally
learned to do what's necessary he's like
i'm not gonna kill you but technically
speaking if i just ride the wind
out the back of this car i'm not killing
you
gravity's technically killing you or the
sudden stop it's you know
technically speaking i don't have to
save you and my moral code's intact
so in that megatron would have died if
batman was there
which means optimus prime's just a bit
too
passive i mean what's that famous
optimus prime line that he says to
megatron you know
one shall stand one shall
fall that's optimus prime saying one of
us is gonna kill each other and i might
be the one to kill you this optimus
prime's like
megatron i know a really good vegan
restaurant not
two blocks away let's go there and talk
this
out i mean if for nothing else imagine
what megatron could do if you let him
live and he gets your matrix of
leadership oh
he got your matrix of leadership your
fault
optimus prime i don't know what to say
it is i don't require
bloodlust from the leader of heroes but
i do doubt this particular leader's
ability to lead his troops
against a bloodthirsty dictator in a
wartime scenario
and at the very end they do crash land
on earth and there's this velociraptor i
mean immediately when you see the
landscape you're like oh beast wars for
sure and this velociraptor blinks it's
like his eyes already robotic so there's
already transformers there it looks like
i do wonder now that megatron has the
matrix of leadership we saw this
this vision of evil optimus prime he's
nemesis prime right that's his name but
it's like is hot rod gonna come into it
i haven't seen him at all
so it's like is is he around at all i
know hot rod was cool i always liked him
it was just cool that the cool guy like
the the awesome yeah hot rod
transformers like oh by the way
he's the new prime he gets to be radimus
prime so in the end this show has that
dark tone that grit that i liked from
the previous season it's called
earthrise
it should be called earth arrival at the
very end
just you know earth i don't know i guess
space drifting
and a fight with scorpenoc didn't have
the same ring to it but earthrise felt a
bit messier than siege i think each of
these seasons
could go for being a bit longer it's
like they want to tell more than they
have the time allotment for so they just
try to cram everything into it i didn't
like it as much as siege
i'll be honest with you and some of that
does come from the fact that optimus
prime just
made me roll my eyes with these idiot
decisions he kept making so yeah siege
set up some really sweet stuff
earthrise felt like a bit of filler to
me had some cool stuff in it absolutely
but
still felt like filler but alright
transformers the war for cybertron
trilogy earthrise have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you